all right joining us now with more
former congresswoman tulsi gabbard is
with us i i particularly tulsi i'd love
to get your reaction to
biden saying the maga crowd is the most
extreme political organization that's
existed in recent american history
uh let's start with antifa blm the group
blm uh what do we want that cops when we
want them now
you're a democrat how do you react to
that because it's obviously ridiculous
it's worse than ridiculous sean it is
absolutely despicable and outrageous
when you look at the president of the
united states of america calling
millions of americans essentially
terrorists people who politically
opposed him or voted against him he's
calling them terrorists in an attempt to
intimidate them
into silence and we know this is because
we've heard this before from both him
and his attorney general you'll remember
when when his attorney general said you
know anyone who holds extremist or
anti-authority views will be targeted
for investigation and potential
prosecution by their domestic terrorist
unit so he's essentially saying that
this quote-unquote maga crowd
are worse than terrorists
this is outrageous and and so for every
american who's watching every american
who's seen this no matter how you feel
about the maga crowd this is an
authoritarian assault on our freedom and
we need to stand together very strongly
against this attempt to intimidate and
silence anyone who holds political views
that are different from or opposed to
what this president and his
administration are furthering it's an
assault on our democracy
i want your thoughts on on the rush to
to cling to this potential decision in
the supreme court that would overrule
v wade number one joe biden supported a
constitutional amendment to get rid of
it interesting he's not been asked the
question ruth bader ginsburg pretty much
saying and arguing what i had said all
my career which i thought it was bad law
it'll be returned to the states abortion
is not going to be unavailable or
illegal in america so they're
demagoguing that issue
i'm arguing the reason they're doing it
is because they don't have anything else
that they can run on and say hey we did
this this and this and we're all all
better off because of it am i wrong
well i think when you look at the
different efforts to assault our freedom
and democracy it continuously points to
the fact that they're afraid of the
people they're afraid of us they're
afraid of this question being put to the
people through their state legislatures
for the people's voices to be heard
i think it's also critical to point out
that
this leak sets a very very dangerous
precedent for our supreme court for
three important reasons number one is
first of all this person is a thief who
stole this information released it with
a very specific intent to try to incite
protesters and intimidate and pressure
our supreme court justices to make a
political decision rather than a
decision that is based
on the constitution
number two we have the fact that um
you know the supreme court is not in
place to legislate from the bench
people's representatives at the state
level at the federal level are charged
to make laws not the supreme court the
supreme court needs to make decisions
based on the constitution and the
department of justice lastly needs to go
and prosecute this
crime which is exactly what it is and
make an example out of the person who
leaked this information because our
supreme court justices cannot operate
under the fear that they will have
partisan political activists in their
house
intimidating and threatening their
ability to do their job per the
constitution and there was a
apparently justice alito was supposed to
give uh remarks at an event and he had
to cancel uh and we know why uh tulsi
gabbard always great to have you thank
you for being with us hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else